big story you probably noticed this  yesterday Facebook's website crashed  yeah the site was apparently offline for  42 minutes now personally I think it's a  shame Facebook wasn't down longer now  I'll tell you why I'll tell you why  because it seems to me that people were  really in that 42 minutes starting to  get things done they were yeah I think  they were in fact in fact we have a  piece of tape from part of that 42  minutes take a look in every simulation  we've run using this micro RNA the t52  enzyme is completely reversed the  malignancy it's all healthy tissue oh my  god I think we just found the cure for  guys Facebook's back Oh Greg and Amy  went to coast  [Applause]  yeah they didn't cure cancer yeah weird  response wasn't that a great clip  subscribe to my youtube channel for an  endless supply of me  [Laughter]